i am blonde i am naturally blonde but i
was
dying my own hair who would have guessed
that these celebrities
actually had their hair dyed for these
iconic roles
certain characters require an actor to
have a specific look
and if they don't naturally have the
hair a character requires
then dyeing the hair is necessary to
obtain the right look
this process of dyeing hair can be long
and complicated
taking up a good portion of one's day
and it can leave some pretty nasty side
effects
including completely destroying the hair
so which actors put their hair on the
line for their roles
and which actors hated their new hair
and which ones preferred the dyed look
let's dive in and find out is sophie
turner
real ginger to get into her role as
sansa stark on game of thrones
sophie turner had to dye her naturally
blonde hair into a gingery orange
she said she was nervous to make the
change and that the process of dyeing
her hair
orange and then dying it back to blonde
almost completely destroyed her hair
so much so that she had to wear a wig
for the final season of game of thrones
as the hair stylist wouldn't allow her
to dye her hair back orange telling her
that her hair would have fallen out
to make matters worse she says she was
kicked on kick a ginger day in the uk
happy national kick a ginger day and
then just like started kicking me and i
was like thanks guys
yikes matt leblanc was only 27 years old
when friends first aired which is why
it is going to surprise you to find out
that he actually had gray hair while
filming for his role as joey
they needed to start dying his hair in
season 2 as the grey was just too
noticeable
and year after year he got more and more
gray hair
requiring more maintenance this is
season one
season two leblanc says the process took
two hours to get his hair properly black
which he wasn't a fan of so he started
dying his own hair
using just for men the first time he did
this however
he forgot to protect his ears and showed
up to work the next day with his ears
dyed black
nowadays though leblanc embraces the
salt and pepper look
when leighton meester went into her
audition for gossip girl
there was one big thing standing in her
way of landing the role of blair
her blonde hair gossip girl co-creator
josh schwartz asked her to dye her hair
for the audition
because blake lively and her character
serena were already the blonde ones
mr obliged dying her hair in the sink
and landing the roll
she seems to have grown a liking to the
color as in 2019
she dyed her hair back to brunette on
her own accord
the hunger games movie was highly
anticipated when it was announced and
possibly the most important aspect of
transitioning the book to screen was
getting katniss everdeen
just right the naturally blonde hair of
jennifer lawrence wouldn't work for the
dark-haired girl from district 13. so
her hair was dyed to match the brown
hair katniss sports in the books
two movies worth of dying took its toll
however and lawrence ended up cutting
her hair into a pixie cut after catching
fire
stating her hair was completely fried
from the hair dye
this resulted in laurence wearing a wig
for the final two hunger game films
that's just fried from being dyed so
much we all remember the classic blonde
look ashley tisdale rocked in high
school musical and the sweet life of
zach and cody
but she's naturally a brunette so dyeing
her hair was necessary to achieve that
look
it took up to four hours to get her hair
dyed the right color
and at first tisdale wasn't too excited
about being blonde
but she learned to love her new hair and
actually kept her blonde hair for quite
some time after her rolls of maddie and
sharpay came to an end
it takes hours to do my hair
jennifer aniston may be known as having
sunkissed blonde hair
but she actually has dark brown hair
naturally
in the film cake she went back to her
more natural roots
dyeing her hair brunette but it didn't
last long
as aniston switched back to her more
iconic blonde after the roll
which color do you prefer for aniston
evan peters first dyed his brown hair
blonde for the role of tate langdon on
american horror story
since then we have seen peter sport many
different colors over the course of
eight seasons on american horror story
this includes a brunette look more
closely resembling his natural hair
color
dark black hair as the character james
march a redhead look for the sixth
season
and even blue hair for the character kai
anderson in the seventh season
at this point we wouldn't be surprised
if you already forgot what his actual
hair color is
kj appa had to transform into a redhead
for his role as archie in riverdale
unlike some of the other actors on this
list appa didn't dye his hair for the
audition
and said that he didn't see anyone else
with red hair at the auditions either
hair dying wasn't a pleasant experience
as appa recalled the two and a half hour
process
it's pretty gnarly man i had to go to
the salon every two weeks to get it dyed
and bleach the stuff
he also went on to say that they
bleached his eyebrows the first couple
of times
which burnt two holes into his skin
ouch you may be used to seeing debbie
ryan with red hair on jessie but her
natural hair color is actually
blonde ryan explained in an interview
that headlines about jessie would
incorrectly state she is a redhead
even though she has never identified
that way no
she said that keeping her hair red
requires a ton of maintenance
and she prefers to keep her hair blonde
because it's who she is
not a character for her role on
shadowhunters
catherine mcnamara went back to her
roots dyeing her hair red for her role
as clary
before the role mcnamara had her hair
dyed blonde
but she went back to her natural red
hair color for the character
she posted pictures on instagram bidding
goodbye to her blonde hair and showed
the process of dying it back to red
shayleen woodley's jet black hair in
season 2 of big little lies was a
departure from her brown hair look in
season 1.
the actress had her hair dyed black and
cut with bangs to get into the character
of jane
since then woodley has returned her hair
to her natural brown color
if season 3 ever happens we wonder if
woodley will change her hair up once
again
rachel brosnahan rocks a signature look
as the title character on the marvelous
miss maisel with her dark brown hairdo
but brosnahan is actually a blonde in
real life
she started dying her hair dark brown
when she was 16
and says she prefers the brown color
over her natural blonde
when i look in the mirror with dark hair
i feel like i see myself
and when i look in the mirror with
blonde hair i see a fun but slightly
different version of myself
she went back to her natural blonde for
the 2020 film omnia woman
one advantage she notes of being known
for having dark brown hair
is that when she is blonde she's more
incognito in public
either way we think she looks great and
now the stage manager is going like this
we all know what that means in show
business rooney mara is almost
completely unrecognizable in her role as
lisbeth in the girl with the dragon
tattoo
while her hair is normally brunette she
dyed it jet black for the film
and cut it into a short pixie cut with
microbangs
not only did they dye her hair but they
also bleached her eyebrows which mara
thinks was the most important part in
creating the character's appearance
when she first looked in the mirror
after these major changes
she was completely freaked out for a
couple of minutes mara eventually came
to grow
so accustomed to her new look however
that when her eyebrows were put back to
normal
she wanted them to be bleached back it
may be hard to picture anna paquin as a
brunette after watching her play sookie
in true blood
but that is in fact her natural hair
color when she first went blonde for the
show
she took a stance against those who
might call her a barbie doll for the new
look
i don't like a barbie doll and probably
never will the second you dye your hair
and get a spray tan
people treat you as if you're a bit
stupider and happier
despite what a few small-minded people
may say
she pulls off the look perfectly and
absolutely kills it in her role as
sookie
the naturally blonde cole sprouse as one
may conjure images from his days on
suite life of zack and cody
ditches that color for black as his
character jughead on riverdale in an
interview with e
sprouse joked that the dark hair helped
people tell him
and his twin apart it makes it easier
for people to tell my twin and i apart
that's for sure
as long as sprouse keeps playing his
role on riverdale we'll continue to see
him with his black hairstyle
transforming into the role of peta for
the hunger games wasn't an easy process
hutcherson had to dye his dark brown
hair blonde and it took
three colorists to get the color just
right he hated how difficult it was to
maintain the color and was ready to get
rid of it as soon as they were done
filming the movies
having to do touch-ups all the time and
get my hair re-dyed and bleached was not
my thing at all
we don't blame you josh for his role as
alex on 13 reasons why heiser changed
his brown hair to bleach blonde
he shared some behind the scenes photos
of the process on instagram with the
caption saying
i don't have a scalp anymore but it was
well worth it sounds like the process
may have been a little harsh on his head
but he was right
it was definitely worth it what's the
first step in becoming one of the
world's most
infamous serial killers dying your hair
of course
the normally dirty blonde ephron dyed
his hair dark black to match that of ted
bundy's real-life hair
it was a great look but was
unfortunately paired with a
representation of a horrible real-life
person
we'll take troy instead any day of the
week those were some of the celebrities
willing to take the plunge
and try out a new hair color for their
role it wasn't for everybody
but there's no denying they looked great
with the new color even if it did leave
some not so desirable side effects
which actor would you like to see with
dyed hair and which actor do you think
had the best dyed hair
let us know